Madam Secretary recently during an
interview on Mexico's Televisa you said
we can't legalize drugs because there's
just too much money in it oh no you see
there's so much money in the drug trade
because of the black market and there
can be black markets in just about
anything
take pants suits if the government made
pant suits illegal you know what on
second thought let's choose something
people like why if the government made
wine illegal what would happen to the
price of wine it'd go up madam secretary
think of it like this government
officials can shut down wine makers and
sellers but they can't shut down your
love of wine or Crown Royal or
Presidente beer and since lots of
Americans like the sauce as much as you
do new people start making and selling
alcohol but these new people are pretty
sketchy
no surprise because what they're doing
is illegal they dodge cops get into turf
wars they could end up dead or in prison
so why do they bother Madam Secretary
it's because they know they can make the
big bucks because they have fewer
competitors and lots of customers that's
what happened during a period called
prohibition there were turf battles over
booze all kinds of violence and what
caused all that bad stuff Madam
Secretary I'll give you a hint alcohol
prohibition causes violence and so does
drug prohibition does there no gangster
shootouts over your Chardonnay
that's because the government sobered up
and ditched alcohol prohibition now if
they'd only wise up on drugs look you're
always on a plane traveling around the
world for work so maybe we can blame
your drug legalization slip of the
tongue on jetlag or too much Crown Royal
you